Wenn du Streit mit deinem
Bruder hast, danke, dass du dir die
Zeit genommen hast, diese Frage zu stellen. Das ist heute das
zweite Mal, dass mir diese
Frage gestellt wurde. Tut mir die Kehle weh, nachdem ich
eine Show gesungen habe? Es tut nie weh
es wird am
nächsten Tag funktionieren, also wenn ich zu viel schreie,
dann weiß ich, dass ich
wegen der Show am nächsten Tag in Schwierigkeiten sein könnte,
also weißt du, manchmal muss
ich es mit den
Stimmbändern schonen  Und was die zweite Frage
angeht: Haben Mike und ich jemals Streit
, wissen Sie, ich glaube, das hatten wir früher,
bevor wir einen Plattenvertrag hatten
und wir
in einem Van in sehr beengten Verhältnissen quer durch Kanada
gefahren sind  Viertel
, das ist, wenn Sie wissen, dass zwei
Geschwister definitiv in Streit geraten können, also
glaube ich, dass wir uns damals gestritten haben und jetzt
streiten Mike und ich nicht mehr wirklich,
weil wir uns den
ganzen Tag über nicht einmal sehen Ich bin auf meinem  Bus
und er ist in seinem Bus und Ryan ist o  In seinem
Bus und und und wir wissen Sie, wenn
wir vor der Show in die Umkleidekabine kommen,
wissen Sie normalerweise, dass
jeder ein breites Lächeln hat, und es ist wie:
Hey, was hast du heute gemacht, weißt du, also sind
wir nicht die Gallagher  Brüder
von Oasis, wenn Sie sich das fragen